[Music]
hello everyone and welcome to simulation
we are featuring John Khan today yeah
thanks for karana the show Wow yeah it
has been a little while I really
appreciate you coming on the show this
is gonna be some really great
conversation John is a partner at
circling Institute you guys have
probably seen some of the videos on our
channel and I can do it a little bit of
justice but you'll do it the most
justice but go ahead and tell us about
what circling Institute yes well
circling I would say is a practice of
communication practice where the context
is purposely set to create deep
connection intimacy like get to know the
heart and soul of somebody like way
beneath just a normal surface
conversation so it's like the cocktail
conversations that drive everybody crazy
it's like well how do you get and you
get below that quickly and on purpose
with somebody but then like how far can
you actually go and it's a few things
one it's it's about like how to
how do we actually get somebody at the
core of that we're like really get what
it's like to be them get their whole
world because I think something happens
when we feel gotten by each other like
everything changes the whole connection
there's a whole new level of trust and
fondness that happens there's there's
something I think healing like when we
feel like it's just the feeling of being
seen and really being gotten and
accepted and sort of unconditionally
loved I think it's rare and a lot of our
sort of Western world upbringings today
so when when I can get created there's
something profound that happens both
like a reconnection with ourself and a
potential of of the type of connections
we can have with each other yeah we see
we seem to be drifting more and more
away from these days with the sort of
the world of technology where you know
we're texting each other you know we
imagine that one day we're gonna be
people are gonna be on a date and we're
gonna be texting each other across the
table I like how you initially use the
word communication as this essence of
the practice communication is almost
everything that humans do has something
to do with communication unless we're
completely silent at a meditation
retreat maybe by ourselves but even then
there's still some sort of communication
when the Gong happens and you all go to
the to the hall the meditation hall so
there's still some sort of communication
even happening then so to feel gotten
whatever the heck that even means we
don't have as much time today that we
say we don't have as much time to get to
know people to ask them really tough
questions about themselves to inquire
about them and then usually when they
say you know I'm feeling a little bit
sad the first thing that comes to mind
is how do I fix that
because I want to help you not be sad
but there is a little bit of beauty in
the sadness and maybe asking more about
why the sadness exists with you and just
being there to listen paraphrase so the
person feels like they actually
understand what's going on yeah I mean
there's so many levels
truth and possibilities to explore what
you should share it I mean this there's
a this level of like we want to fix it
because we care right and that just
seems to be like what our attention is
on like how can we solve this and move
on and how can I help you in the
quickest amount of time but we find that
that doesn't necessarily lead to deeper
connection and intimacy it's more of a
like a transactional type experience and
I think this there's something about the
willingness to really be with a person
in the complete truth of what is that's
where healing a connection happens and I
think people with such in a rush today
that it's so it's sometimes hard to do
that but also we haven't really been
trained to do that
most of the even our deeper
conversations I notice who are sort of
about things that are going on in our
lives versus the depth of our experience
in relationship to what's going on in
our life yeah and and and what does that
say about who we are and all that I
think sometimes it's it's hard for
people to to not want it fixed sometimes
because what we already said but also
sometimes because it might trigger
something in them that reminds them of
what they just heard and they it might
be hard for them to be with that
situation in themselves so like let me
fix it in you so I don't have to feel it
in myself
but something different happens when
we're willing to to be with it I think
you also reference the connection being
amplified between two people the
oxytocin the trust this love this
oneness between the two these don't get
the they don't get the light that they
deserve to get in today's world because
of everything else that we're doing so
much I think we spent more time not sure
of course but I think we spent more time
in the past doing a little bit more of
the just getting each other because
there was less things to to do yeah
there's less we had our attention on I
mean I just just my own childhood I
remember my my parents would if they
weren't helping us with our homework or
taking us shopping for something we
needed they were usually sitting in the
living room reading books or talking and
that was at least a few nights a week I
mean it was a much slower pace of life I
can't even imagine doing that these days
it's just like way too much to do and
that was just this last generation I
mean if you just think back to our our
roots you know for we sort of came
indoors right maybe a couple thousand a
few thousand years ago it's much more
tribally oriented
you know the stereotype of sitting
around the campfire and talking with
each other and everything our history
was passed down through stories through
getting to know each other Oh a whole
different pace of life yeah like to me
that I think there's so much stress
these days because people are at a pace
of life that's to me at least seems sort
of like out of sync with like the
heartbeat of the earth I like that way
of putting it yeah and there's so
there's something I think happens when
we take the time to really sink in with
each other it's almost like we have to
slow down we have to slow down to really
hear and feel what's in each other's
heart we can't just get it on an
intellectual level because there's a
different speed that happens there like
to really tune in and attune to each
other it takes like the breath to feel
into what's happening you know and and I
think something happens when like when
we're willing to be with the depths of
each other and with and to welcome
whatever is and to let that tendency to
want to fix things Pass
we get to the places where we've been
uncomfortable maybe the wounds that
we've been carrying around a whole life
that we've been avoiding and we haven't
wanted to feel it so we kind of
orchestrated our whole life to avoid
these things being triggered or having
to deal with them and then when we find
somebody who's actually willing to sit
with us and not just kind of get it but
welcome it and want to explore it and
want to like look at it with us hold it
for reality now all the sudden there's a
safety oh there's a safety to maybe
explore places in me that before I felt
alone maybe I felt a little bit crazy
but like why is this such an issue or
something like that now somebody's
helping me make sense of it they're sort
of looking at it through my eyes they're
getting me around it I feel sane I feel
accepted I feel safe like now you can
sink into it and usually sometimes is
there's a well of not just avoidance but
old pain maybe there's some emotion
there or whatever but I find usually
when we're we get to that point where
with people and and and and now they're
they're willing to face it because they
have company below that there's a level
of wisdom you know that they forgot they
had like and now they're they're tuning
into something deeper in themselves like
a connection to source of their own
coalescence or whatever you want to call
it their soul and they start to come up
with their own answers probably better
answers then then our advice might have
been for them yeah and that to me that's
a beautiful thing and and yet in that
there's a tremendous intimacy and deep
connection
that happens I think we've all mostly
crave that I mean I think human beings
are yeah we're here for growth we're
here definitely to learn and create
we're also here for love like an if
that's missing so much in the meaning of
life is missing and it's funny how we in
some ways I think we've been taught to
protect or be careful or be in fear of
the thing that we're actually wanting
the most just a love each other but it
takes a risk because like it requires us
to reveal ourselves like to reveal that
that well of stuff that that's like I
might I might not just be hiding from
you I might be hiding from myself mm-hmm
there's a good lyric revealing the
layers to my soul and the practice of
circling reveals the layers but first
one must want to reveal the layers and
the the layers get stacked on the more
technology kind of drives our world and
so then it's harder to shed the layers
because we're focused on top of all of
these layers all the time in our culture
and our day-to-day so you see if I want
to I care you are you you like I see us
it's like you're incredibly brilliant
intellectually you can do nothing
you seem to be able to communicate with
anybody on any topic even though you're
not trained in it right there's somehow
you're tapped into some level of
infinite intelligence yet you could just
totally get consumed in that but I see
in you like a really rich heart and a
deep desire to connect and bond with
people and so how did you get past those
layers now I'm interviewing you
I know nothing I know nothing because
especially about the human to human
connection for sure nothing huh yeah
the layers are interesting because we
don't even know that the layers are
there yeah and we how are you well I'm
good that classic one if we actually
just slowed down and took the time to be
like how do I feel in this moment and
just said the actual feeling to the
person that would even change a society
quite a bit and then of course the other
person must be willing to to be with
that feeling it's hard if you're at a
checkout of a store and you're like how
are you yeah because what are you gonna
have 10 seconds 15 seconds so versus
when you actually slow down with
somebody fern hour and even then a lot
of our conversations today in the
business world are well how can I be
useful to you how can you be useful it's
not like you know your grandmother just
died how does that make you feel what
are you going through right now and just
being with the feelings of what that is
for me it's always a insatiable
curiosity Einstein I have no special
talent I'm just an insatiable curious
and insatiably curious about fearing out
human to human but I'm also a little bit
critical of the amount of time that I
pass on that as well you pass a lot of
time mastering this and that's who you
are that's your essence of mastering
this and me on the other hand I Intuit
and I want to slowly slower master it
because I'm also focusing on mastery of
being an interlocutor and stuff but at
the same time I think circling enables
people to have space to to vent it
enables people to have space to be with
someone else's feelings and really get
each other that is very important but I
think there's also a level of just
having maybe an excessive amount of
needing to just
it's a needing to just please be with my
feelings please be with my feelings the
next week be with my feelings you know
there is a little bit of an ego Drive in
the world to also want to provide some
sort of utility to the world and we
can't just we won't boot can't provide
utility if we're constantly in the need
for somebody to be with how we feel so I
think there's an interesting you know
plug into circling but also plug back
into the world and yeah and I think
circling empowers you to plug back into
the world with the more effective vibe
for yourself for your essence and for
the essence of humanity so seven years
as a partner at circling Institute this
has been probably how many people have
you seen tens of thousands of people and
so this is all different types of
flavors of humans you've got to know
humans better than definitely in the top
one percent of people because you've
gotten to know the true essence of
another person and all these different
flavors
have you found patterns
I mean I think there's a there's a basic
disconnect happening today that we
already talked about just people feeling
disconnected from each other people
feeling disconnected from themselves I
think like you said they're they're like
there has to be a mapping over to real
life as well
and
I think when you start to develop
communication skills will you get the
nuances of what's happening in
communication yeah and when you can
actually get what's going on with
somebody it Maps over over the business
and map so over to your family it Maps
over to your partner Maps over it you
know to your friends and there's there's
no situation where it doesn't have an
impact true right and like you become I
watch people who go through our
trainings and stuff I'd like people who
are really committed stay there a long
time and there's something that changes
that like you can you can actually tell
from across the room you look at them
and like whoa there's a whole level of
presence there's a comfortability in
their own body there's a willingness to
to welcome anything somebody brings to
them so I find like those are the people
who end up just magnetizing people to
them yeah like they become valuable
people that people want to do business
with them because it's it's easy it's
like they if it's just a transaction
like they get the purpose they get the
understanding of it the willingness
they're willing to talk about anything
that any dissonance anything that seems
off or it doesn't seem like it might
work that's just a really crisp
communication that can happen there and
yet on a personal level that's the
person that's phenomenally valuable
because they know like you said like
sometimes we don't even get past the
first layer with each other like even
sometimes good friends let alone peers
in a work environment you've been with
each other for years and still don't
know the first thing about each other
maybe friends know the details and
oftentimes the conversation is around
the details it's like well catch me up
like how was your week or what you've
been what do you been doing
and they say something or how are you
and you like you said one one level of
emotion go oh and the traditional answer
is like okay got it it's like you know
got it you've just got the first layer
of what's going on I guess she's just
keep asking and looking for like what's
like what's really alive there yeah like
what's the what's the thread that goes
like all the way down that's connected
to something deep because we all have
those in our life we don't have those
places that either we're ignoring or we
have our attention on because we can't
not ever attention on it looks a little
reactionary versus inquisitorial about
your recent project that you are working
on you can ask Oh like why why were you
working on that project versus to be
like oh I was working on a project to
last week let me tell you about
so there's yeah that's where like most
people don't listen like we we listened
for what we're gonna say next or for
what we're gonna contribute or whatever
but really deeply listening to somebody
then we're not just listening but adhere
to hear the details of what they said
we're listening for like the meaning of
it to them yep thank
what really matters and why like he said
like what like why did you work on that
project like what's what what is it
feeding in you you know what's what's
the desire there what's what's the value
and even deeper like what does it say
about who you are and maybe your mission
here and your challenges and yeah I like
that face you the face actually kind of
feeds into what you said earlier that I
wanted to make sure to comment on but it
was the word nuance nuance and
communication and how that actually pans
over to every other aspect of our lives
family work friends everywhere nuance
and this can be everything from like you
were just indicating a nice movement of
the eyebrows you can just do something
like and if you just transition your
face to these different expressions you
don't even need words I don't even need
to say words to you for you to feel like
I'm absorbing what you're saying yeah
with a high efficiency and so that level
of nuance when you bring that into
business and family people register that
you recently was learning about how the
eyebrows literally evolved for a deeper
expression of nuance and emotion that's
great and I mean we know nothing but
we're just we're trying to figure things
out and to be able to to leverage nuance
we don't even need the vocal cords we
can just have these different facial
expressions I'm practicing silence
practicing not speaking and then also
practicing a paraphrasing what one is
feeling and this works like you said as
well in business and family I think the
relatability of this practice
to the other aspects of our lives is
always really important how do you plug
it back into culture and into the world
yeah it's good to be with you you too
John yeah you take a couple of our
weekends
I love circling house it's sitting with
you right now yeah
circling has but I think circling was
the thing that really taught me about
the difference between just listening
and being with someone's feelings versus
giving them advice and that was probably
one of my biggest takeaways from
circling because I used to you know some
people that wash us really know me and
they know that whenever I talk to people
I'm always you know actively listening
paraphrasing but then I send over advice
as well and a lot of people want that
and a lot of people you know take that
advice and they run with it and they're
like yeah like worked or maybe didn't
work cedra but now there's a difference
between when you don't give advice when
you're just listening paraphrasing being
with the feelings totally different vibe
some people that want advice don't want
that some people that don't want advice
want you to just be with their feelings
so it's also important to know to maybe
ask in the flow of conversation or even
before conversation starts yeah because
it's a whole different conversation when
when you're when you're wanting advice
it's like hey let's let's brainstorm
let's see let's see what we can create
like that's that's just a you have your
attention on something different so it's
a different context then you ask prior
to the conversation starting would you
like advice or would you like us to just
be with how you're feeling do you do
that or how there's a good way to go
about that yeah if I don't know like a
lot of times you can just tell you can
tell yeah interesting but
I mean you know again depends on on the
context if he's just hanging out with a
friend and a friend is bringing you a
problem with something like that then
yeah and that in that moment I might ask
because it might be more important hmm
to just she just actually be with them
and explore what it's like for them so
they so they're so they feel understood
and you actually understand them so you
start with being with the feelings and
not giving advice and then maybe down
the line of the conversation you'll say
are you interested in hearing some
thoughts that might be advice are
helpful to what's going on yeah I think
if I was going to do that I probably
yeah I'd probably do it when like in a
way that that exploration or that part
of the whole conversation or journey
together was over ah and then now we're
at like and now we're gonna pipe in
place they weren't a different okay like
a different context because I more and
more when I'm with somebody on that
level of exploration and you get down in
into stuff you know in in in the human
experience there's often a lot of stuff
there that's really tender and
it strikes me as like that that's a
sacred place it's like sacred space and
so I don't like bringing advice into the
sacred to me the sacred is just like
it's like it's your experience your
journey your growth your wounds your
broken hearts your desires like that's
just to be honored mm-hmm honored
appreciated welcomes loved yeah like I
said and then like the person like just
trusting that a person does have their
own wisdom like we all have our own
internal guidance and if if we trust
somebody enough so that they remember to
trust themselves like we we usually find
it yeah and then the exploration and
advice-giving and things like that I I
have less and less need or desire to
actually do that these days I find do
you think that once you peel the layers
from just paraphrasing and being with
someone's feelings and they peel the
layers back themselves to the essence to
the source once they get there and they
have a profound experience at that point
then the advice is unneeded because the
essence came alive enough to where there
was a realization yeah you know it
doesn't mean that sometimes people don't
sometimes need direction or support or
howl board or training or like I'm just
help understanding their choices
so they could make a good informed
decision yeah but to me that's that's a
different level of giving advice
I like this analogy a lot of the layer
is being peeled back by a process of of
venting holding space for somebody to
just be with their feelings now when
people peel back the layers sometimes
there are quite deep aspects to their
character to their being to their past
to their present to the way that they're
feeling sometimes it's trauma from the
past sometimes it's a fear that's coming
up there's oh there's these different
aspects that that come up of people's
character and usually when the layers
get peeled back there can be some pretty
interesting exploration that occurs for
them yeah usually the you know our
wounds are emotional they're messy and
we've been trying to keep them under
wraps for so long that when they finally
do come out
you know this sort of come out all over
the place
and
knowing that somebody can actually be
with that is what makes the difference
as to whether someone's even willing to
to go there that's why we're so we tend
to hide that stuff from ourselves for so
long yeah but there's something but
there's a there's a difference because
I'm hearing our conversation and it's
almost starting to sound a little bit
like how do you be with somebody and do
therapy or something like that and
that's not really where like we come
from you're circling it so like somehow
when we when we get all the way through
like a deep connection like that or
quote a circle like with your attention
on somebody it's often very therapeutic
I just don't see that that's not the
agenda exactly gender is actually no
agenda
yeah right and it's just to be with each
other to me the agenda is like how do we
create intimacy and connection and love
right and so these are just the
practices that we found seem to do that
that seems to be the map for how human
beings get there yes yes so a lot of it
so the difference in therapy is is a
couple things one is we're sharing our
own experience as well and willing to
reveal it so it's not just like me
asking you questions and exploring your
world to try to make you feel safe and
all that because if I just kept doing
that then I can sound like a therapist
or I can sound like an interrogator I
can't just keep asking you questions and
then I find in most conversations at
some point it'll start to feel unsafe
it's like wait a second you're just
asking me all the questions like I keep
revealing myself but you don't seem to
have any skin in the game like you don't
have anything at stake and as soon as
like we start to reveal ourselves and
our own vulnerability it's like oh like
Alan being with you
I noticed I'm feeling I'm feeling really
alive I'm feeling excited I'm feeling
some love for you I'm feeling still a
little scared because I don't want to
[ __ ] up the podcast we like to say [ __ ]
yeah of course yeah we say [ __ ] all the
time so now like now like any time you
like we reveal our own experience
generally we don't really know what's
gonna happen next we don't know it's the
person going to accept me are they gonna
judge me am I gonna feel embarrassed are
they gonna think I'm weird and
disconnect like we just don't know and
so there's a risk there and and the
other person feels that risk like they
feel that willingness like I'm offering
something of myself to you my own
experience and as you feel that you go
oh like he's being a little bit
vulnerable like he doesn't know how I'm
gonna react and somehow it creates a
little bit more of a permission for you
to do the same and that's the invitation
for death so that's that Express that's
like the first thing is you have to
start with yourself
we call that sovereign we have a whole
weekend training about that it's
actually coming up in a few weeks but so
it's like how do you know your own truth
your own experience how do I actually
know how I feel so many people today
don't even know how they feel there's so
up in technology that they're
disconnected from their own experience
so part of that is redeveloping that
comfort in your own skin again and and
the knowing of yourself like what am I
actually experienced how do I feel
emotionally emotions give us a
tremendous amount of information about
the truth and the rightness of
of our direction and what we're doing
and if it makes sense to us right so
being willing to reveal that to another
human being like now we can feel each
other and there's such a richness like
that's to me that's like the beginning
of of love and care for each other it's
like the willingness to feel each
other's experience and feel each other's
humanity yeah so if I can share that
with you now makes a little bit safer
for you to share that with me now as you
share with me I can start to feel into
what it's now that I know me I can start
to feel into what it's like to be you
and that's the other part of it so
that's we call that the Explorer all
right so let's go explore your world
together even to the point that we find
like uncharted territory like parts of
you that you don't even you know you
can't even explain to me because you
don't even know it yet and now we're in
it together and that's really exciting
mm-hmm when we get to discover you
together like the newness of you the
parts that haven't been revealed to
yourself yet yeah that's exciting yeah
so sovereignty first know thyself yes
and maybe we can get a couple more items
there as we got to the next one was Co
exploring together Explorer um but let's
let's take a brief at know thyself first
yeah as we take a pit stop there you
said to feel okay so I feel how I'm
feeling okay maybe there's maybe I was
just on the street and there was a lot
of noise on the street and it was kind
of making me feel uneasy why don't we go
ahead why don't we make it more real
let's make more real what's it like to
be with me right now
feels like we're Co exploring and
and what's the feeling of Co exploring
for you
the feeling of coke exploring feels like
I'm diving into the pool of wisdom so
I'm like now I'm swimming I'm swimming
in what we're calling exciting does it
feel soft does it feel relaxing like
that one's soft it off feels very soft
yeah yeah almost like the way you
describe the like velvety yes velvety
that's good yeah yeah yeah and so the
example of what you just did was you
further asked and you wanted to know
about how it was feeling and so in that
same example once we kind of know
ourselves and how we're feeling about
our day-to-day actions we're evolving of
involving almost everything then it
makes it easier for us to inquire about
how somebody else is feeling
and then we explore further right okay
so then we get the book which has to do
with the the other sort of basic skill
or capacity that we we described in this
practice which is called speaking the
moment speaking the moment right so
we're not so right now like we can be
talking about circle and we can be
talking about technology or the world or
our mystery of connection or whatever or
we can be talking about our connection
right now and what's happening which was
the soft velvety swimming that was the
moment yeah right so actually speaking
what's happening between two people is
something that Moses most of Western
world today avoids like crazy world it's
talking like we get together we're
talking about some third thing yeah the
football game or something we purchased
or they're how to grow the business the
business
yeah yeah versus actually what's
happening right now
yeah which tends to be what's most alive
you know speaking you do that and just
people like like they just light up or
they go into terror but something
happens something which happens it
brings me back though to that balance
between investing lots of time into just
being with feelings and then also being
focused on trying to leverage time to
bring some sort of utility to the world
as well at a larger scale so that being
able to swing back and forth between the
two is something that I care about a
tremendous amount okay maybe we go into
third from the know thyself sovereignty
to the Explorer Co exploring with
somebody this is kind of the circling
Institute's what would you call this the
I guess you would call it sort of a
model of this type of authentic relating
or the depth of where this practice can
go it's part of what we call the seven
stages of circling which is actually
there's a like a two-hour webinar on our
website link in the bio so check it out
you have somebody wanted to just sort of
understand the whole model and get some
practical applications that they can
start using their life right away that's
a good place to start yeah so the first
two stages of that seven stages of
circling is sovereign and Explorer
number three number three yeah yeah of
course
number three we actually just had the
weekend in our year-long training on it
this past weekend it's number three is
warrior and so warrior is most people
think of warriors like a challenge
like me challenging you which which is
completely not what we would call
warrior you could there might be aspects
of that but it's it's sort of more like
instead of me being a warrior at you
it's being a warrior for you mm-hmm and
so I might notice something that's off
like some dissonance like you might be
talking about how happy you are with
everything you're doing and yet I'm
noticing a frown and you're almost in
tears I know like what's going on here
like I said is there something off for
you right yeah who are you or you might
just say something that is really
impactful for me but you might just say
nonchalantly and go right by it like you
gave an example there's like somebody
just died or something like that like oh
yeah my like a grandfather just died I
just went to the funeral and then I came
back and I'd always worked to do and
like well wait a second father just died
oh my god like were you close to him
just exploring it like so just like
stopping it like helping a person stay
with the truth of what is that might be
something that really matters to them
and somehow they're it's hard to for
them to be with it so they're forgetting
how much it matters so warrior is like
pointing to that and like bringing it
that right back there so that they can
be with it and you can be and you get
the richness of being with it with them
because that's probably one of the
things that has the most meaning in
their life at this moment in time right
so that's where the most juice is gonna
be
it takes a certain amount of confidence
in oneself to pause the other person as
they're trying to breathe by my
grandfather just died I'm going back to
work and it's like pause but were you
close
how do you feel you what was time like
with your grandfather you know the that
I love that cuz we fail so much as we
try and figure out how to do that and so
the fear of failing holds people from
ever breaking that flow oh do you try to
breathe by because they didn't want to
talk about it themselves right or it's
like oh I don't want I don't want to do
something wrong with you or I don't want
to make you feeling make you feel
uncomfortable right if you were breezing
by that it's like you're you're moving
away from that because you already feel
discomfort around it right so and you'll
probably you know the are deepest wounds
it's like we're feeling uncomfortable
around them every day of our lives
we're just numb to it and so we like we
never heal them we're just always
avoiding them and it takes a lot of
energy to resist something to the point
that you're not willing to feel it
anymore and as your Gary keyboard
keyboard run to the next thing
phone call phone call keyboard keyboard
run to the next thing and then when I
forget the chance to sit down Oh John
like I don't can't be vulnerable with
John I don't want to share this
information with John well John even
really care exactly to see that time for
me and so it so when you sense that in
somebody else that's why it's worried
because Wow it takes something it takes
overcoming my own fear like I'm gonna
mess you up or I'm you're gonna be mad
at me for talking having you ask you to
talk about that or I'm gonna hurt you in
some way versus wait a second like like
this seems to matter so like I have to
be willing
I have to be willing to get past my own
stuff and maybe your own stuff to say oh
wait a second that that seems really
important to you yeah like I like that's
where my attention is right now oh my
god like I don't want to talk about the
work stuff yet if you're like if you're
really hurting about that like let's
talk about that for a few minutes yeah I
want to UM between go to four cuz I just
want to I want to make sure that we can
get one do you want one all seven now I
want to get I want to get through the
model cuz I think the models really
important to talk about yeah
so for his deep-sea divers so typically
what happens when you when you get to
the warrior phase right you're you're
pointing at something that if you really
follow it down and usually why are we
avoiding something because it usually
leads like what I've been metaphorically
pointing is here boy I must have a lot
of unprocessed wounds right here keep
going like this so like those are our
core wounds and so when we start to get
in there the reason we've been avoiding
them is because they usually are messy
and they're full of emotion and and
we're we're terrified that if we go
there we're gonna get lost in them like
we'll never find our way out I'll never
be able to get back to work I'll never
be able to get effective again I'm gonna
I'm just gonna be in my suffering when
it's no I should I know the contrary
that it makes us much better at
everything else we do in life because
you've been fighting that it's been
taking so much energy to suppress it
that a big chunk of our energy we don't
even know where it went
right and so when we get in there and it
finally opens up when we finally you
know maybe for five minutes or five days
or whatever we become a hot mess and
begin someone's there to like hold us
and be in it with us and make sense of
it usually now it's so much of that
energy that we that we spent fighting it
and avoiding it it's freed up
but that process of getting in there and
going down and once we get like this
takes it that's the warrior of like we
call it kind of like sealing the exits
but not in a bad way and I can in a
loving way it's like no like let's let's
not change the topic to these different
things like this seems to be so
important and worthy of our exploration
right if you want it's not about your
horsing a correct staying with somebody
like in the truth of what is right but
also having the sovereignty right like I
care about this like like like this is
where my attention is this is where my
desire is like I want to know about that
that's that seems rich so that's the
warrior because it takes something and
then when we get in there we get into
whatever this stuff is or the topic is
it might not be wounds it might be like
this is where your joy and your passion
and your ecstasy is but you haven't been
paying attention to it right whatever
but that's the deep sea diver when you
sort of follow that thread really deep
into like the essence of who that person
is this is very interesting because a
little over a year ago I was doing a
presentation at first robotics world
championship and I was literally
presenting the submarine as it's crazy
because we didn't know each other then
and you guys were talking about deep-sea
divers and I was in Houston and doing a
presentation on the submarine and the
importance of going from the surface
level conversation as you go dive deeper
with somebody with your submarine
submarines gonna get some you know some
some dents there's gonna be some issues
that happen with the with the mechanics
of the submarine over time and that you
gotta just you know with the failure
you're gonna resurface patch up the
submarine and go right back down and how
did you know all that it's just so
fascinating that but this is tapped into
universal intelligence somehow it's
great that you guys are doing deep-sea
diver I was talking about submarine so
fascinating
I think that does have to do with that
that ocean of wisdom that Lake of Wisam
pool of wisdom I'm just tapping into it
from different angles and so okay that's
force deep-sea diver how about five
so then something happens when you get
through that you get to the bottom of
that and you get like through whatever
you've been trying to get through
because usually it's there's so much
resistance it's a pretty narrow pathway
through it you know it's like there's
metaphors and literature about stuff
like that like the dark night of the
soul or like walking through the valley
of death kind of think right well or
like a spiritual crisis some people call
it or whatever
but when you finally get find your way
through which is much easier to do when
you have somebody like in that with you
that you trust and you feel safe with
and it's helping you make sense of it
right like a fresh set of eyes and as
well someone that's not judging you
because we're probably judging the crap
out of ourselves you know our whole life
around stuff like this I have to shame
there and all sorts of horrible stuff
when we get through it and usually I
mean like when we're in this kind of
depth of conversation like people
usually get through it and so then
they're like something opens up like so
all the sudden it's like a watch like a
whole new perspective a whole new piece
of mind a whole new way of looking at
something literally something new has
been born and so that face we called
midwife it's like the birth of something
new like warriors
so like warrior what what is that
that's our 15 minute our 15-minute glass
I love that you I mean we I was like
hourglass no it's a 15 minute glass but
we call it a quarter hour glass yeah
that's probably right quarter hour glass
so yeah it's and they say it's nice it
it also and it's pretty yeah and there's
something about the way that we can tie
the sand
falling with time right yeah that's so
interesting yeah yeah
so Midwife can also maybe be like a
Genesis yeah yeah okay
so like if you if you like we called it
the warrior seeing what hasn't been seen
because the attention is off of
something and help pointing out Oh like
you haven't we haven't seemed like
you've been noticing this right and then
and then the deep-sea diver is feeling
what hasn't been felt right that's where
all the turmoil is I'm avoiding feeling
it alright let's what if we felt that
together what what's in there what's
what are you afraid of what's the truth
of what's actually there right
what does it mean to you and then and
then like something new birth or
something new midwife yeah and it's like
seeing your whole life or the moment or
your challenge or your wound sing it
with completely new eyes or new
possibility there was a there was this
feeling of me not ever being heard by
anybody else talking about the death of
my grandfather that was finally able to
come to light through me how I felt
about it thanks to somebody else and
taking time in the space for me to have
that feeling and have that midwife
experience okay how about well they
might I mean there's probably wouldn't
been that simple probably would have
been like we would have just kept
exploring deeper and deeper and like the
grandfather would have represented
something else in your childhood that
you just you never had from anybody else
and blah blah probably would have been a
whole major story around correct
what what six so six is so what once
that and the Midwife usually just takes
that's again the sacred space it just
takes like a tenderness almost like a
new babies being born to just be with it
and just point to all it's like
something just changed like what's new
and it's like letting the person speak
to that and as as as words or attention
are being given to that usually there's
an integration that just starts to
happen yep like like their whole history
and their relationship to the history
leading up to that starts to look
different like they they start to see it
through different eyes so they would
kind of reframe it all and the president
looks different yep and then how
tomorrow occurs to them they see it
through through a different level of
possibility of what's how they can how
they can be with it what they can do how
the world occurs to them like everything
changes so that's we call that stage
integration yep yeah integration is so
crucial for so much awareness expansion
okay but how do we integrate that into
our lives as we move on yeah that's a
big part of like psychedelics assets
psychotherapy as well right now as an
integration portion of it the circling
process integrating the Midwife into
yeah yep yeah because if it's not gonna
have if it's not going to enrich our
meaning and our ability to function and
bring this into our life then like why
are we doing it and is how I would if
that six is integration what seven seven
is completion completion so how do you
how do you artfully complete either any
process any moment any connection with
somebody in a way that's elegant that
maybe speaks to and again speaking the
moment like what just happened like what
what did we just go through together
yeah and speaking it as a way of
honoring it and bringing like bringing
reality to it like oh yeah that just did
happen didn't it like we're on the same
page about that like you noticed it
happened you got that I noticed it
happen like we like yeah I think we get
that ant pen is and that creates an
invitation for something next time yeah
you know so many people today it's like
in the conversation I'll see ya good
talking to you versus wow I really
appreciated this time with you like it's
like you've kind of in some ways youth
made me forget that there's even a
camera here and there's an outside world
and all that because there's such a
level of care and interest I get from
you and your presence and just it just
feels like a delicious level of
Brotherhood every time I see you
likewise yeah and that's a huge goal as
well as to make him feel like it's just
too that the many don't even exist that
times the cameras on you in there
and then at the time when it's like hey
the links in the bio to check out
circlings it's like oh yeah there are
like there's somebody watching and there
are people watching and they can check
it out
so yeah the fool
so speaking the appreciation usually has
a lot to do with creation yeah that's
good or yeah might be it might not be
appreciation it might be well so like we
just had a big argument and it seems
like like we haven't solved it like
we're not at the end of this weird like
we're like we're stuck right now so like
okay let's let's just be true about
where we are right now like we're stuck
so why don't we why don't we sleep on it
for a day a week and once and like and
come back and and like like I'm
committed to getting through this with
you are you are you committed you know
well maybe it's like you know we
like we just don't work and we don't
have any really good reason to work so
let's just agree to disagree and and say
goodbye and like yeah have a beautiful
light you know it's like whatever
there's like a completion that people
can leave and actually feel complete and
walk away with some level of meaning or
some level of like hopefully
anticipation for a future connection yep
you know yeah sovereignty explorer
warrior deep-sea diver midwife
integration completion yeah seven parts
to the model of the circling Institute
there's sessions happening in San
Francisco and Berkeley across the United
States now even in Europe you can find
circling going on so definitely look up
the different locations for through the
circling Institute and circling Europe
and go and find these locations go spend
a little bit of time trying to better
understand peel back the layers to our
own soul and also help you there while
other people do it for themselves
let's ask a couple questions on our way
out that we typically ask first question
what's the most beautiful thing in the
world
I'd say two things love and any any
expression of love either towards
yourself towards another person towards
the world we live in and I think what I
might call just a different aspect of
love but a level of connection to source
of of connection to you know to the
other dimensions of reality that are not
seen but we but we can tune into and
maybe have some level of faith that
there's way more to us than where and
then were paying attention to right now
or turned on to and that level of
possibility ya know was one of my
friends Heidi recently expanded in my
way of thinking to understanding like
matters only 4% and the dark matter the
dark energy are ninety-six percent and
just like the physical world is limited
and the energetic world is just so
unknown even the tiniest atom or the
tiniest particle of physical existence
is something like you know more than 99%
empty space so like what's the empty
space its energy you know the quantum
physicists are already recognizing and
experimenting and finding that its
energy and it's held together by
intelligence so like what's the
intelligence as our planets and stars
and solar systems so much empty space
yeah
how about do you think we're alone in
the cosmos how could that even be
remotely possible given what we just
talked about I think there's like
infinite levels of dimensions like we're
looking at the universe as being
infinite and constantly expanding and I
think think that's just by one of a
billion planes of dimensionality in
existence
so I don't I don't even you know I you
know I'm a little wacky when it comes to
that stuff like I mean I don't even
believe we're alone in this room I just
think our eyes aren't tuned in to what
our our spirit if we would could could
connect back into the like our divine
birthright of our soul and remembering
like the gods that we actually are and
we can see on that dimension we'd be
seeing a whole level of of other
realities and who knows you know
existence of beings and God and whatever
I'm ready to augment our perception to
be able to tap into the energies that we
don't actually feel or understand a lot
of people are very acute with their
awareness in that sense and because
they've trained it for a long time and I
think you're doing a lot of that
circling definitely does that um do you
think that there is a designer to the
universe are we in a simulation so
you're sort of asking me like my my
spiritual story I think it's a mixture I
don't know if that's called duality like
cuz sometimes when you look at stuff
like this it's like whoa here how many
John's there are here's my here's my
like playful belief about about
existence like to me let's like if you
know even the Bible says before there
was anything there was like quote the
word right which I I think I was just
energy like pure intelligence right and
so if you if you give a little kid if
you put a little kid on a beach and
they're playing with sand by definition
everything they create is gonna be made
of sand right so if prior to existence
all you had was God and then God decides
to create the heaven and earth and
mankind and animals and human beings and
all that by definition
everything had to be made of God so I
don't think God created heaven and earth
than man and humankind I think God
became heaven and earth and man and
humankind so might might my playful
fantasy is like infinite intelligence
after a while
it's got to get boring because you know
everything so like let me split into a
billion particles maybe there's still a
core maybe not but you know maybe it's a
dimensionality thing it's like across
all existence so there's still that
infinite intelligence that knows itself
but it's also like a billion particles
that have now been given free will so
like go create go get into trouble go
forget who you are even go into like
third dimensional reality were just
physical form and we completely forget
that the other 98% of our existence and
see what we create and see how we
discover ourselves again and we create
ourselves without the full knowledge of
ourselves right and now as we different
parts of God communicate with each other
like we discover new things that we
didn't know before about each other and
about ourselves mm-hmm that's my playful
analogy of existence love taking all
that in yes John thank you so much for
this session and we have so much more to
unpack I know there's so many more
questions that we wanted to ask and
we'll have to make it happen soon we'll
have a couple circlings that we're gonna
do after this so I'll circle John John
will circle me so we'll go through this
process and should be showing that to
you guys
links in the bio for circling it's to go
check it out check out a session go to
one go give it a go tell two people
about what you learned today have them
go tell two people let's go start
spreading the message around if you guys
had a good time you know so the comments
and the bio let us know what you thought
subscribe share the content go and
create with it don't just consume go
make go make a write-up write write
something about it make a video about it
start a business about it do cool things
like that and join us we need to
continue grow
in the studio the project paying the
team members making more impact so join
us on patreon we now accept
cryptocurrency the link is both in the
bio as well as at patreon so much love
everyone thanks for tuning in thanks to
Ron Vargas our producing partner team
thanks John thank you very much
alright bye everyone
[Music]
[Music]